-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden
and First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
hosted a Halloween event
on Monday at the White House
which featured
a "Hallo-READ" theme
where children received books.
Meanwhile, at Mar-a-Lago,
former president Trump
also gave trick-or-treaters
some reading material.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden hosted
a Halloween trick-or-treat event
on Monday at the White House,
and it was going pretty great
until Commander ate a Minion.
[ Laughter ]
"Bit a Minion" probably
would've been better,
'cause now the joke
is he ate a kid.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden reportedly
became increasingly concerned
about artificial intelligence
after watching the new
"Mission: Impossible" movie.
And he must have done
a movie marathon,
because tomorrow night
he's giving a prime-time address
about sandworms.
[ As Biden ] They're real big,
folks, and they're real hungry.
[ Normal voice ] Ahead of
Donald Trump Jr.'s testimony
in the Trump Organization's
ongoing civil fraud trial,
former president Trump
attacked the judge
in an early-morning post
today on Truth Social
and warned him to
"leave my children alone,"
adding, "you know, like I did."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden traveled today
to a family farm in Minnesota.
Said Kamala Harris,
"Go on, boy, you're free.
Get. Go on."
[ Laughter, applause ]
Republican presidential
hopeful Chris Christie
said in a new interview
that former White House
chief of staff
Mark Meadows's immunity deal
with federal prosecutors
means former president Trump
is going to be convicted
and added, "It's over."
And I take his word for it
because historically,
it takes Chris Christie
a long time
to admit when something's over.
[ Laughter ]
In a new podcast interview,
Florida governor Ron DeSantis
was asked
if the cowboy boots he is often
photographed wearing have heels,
and he would have walked
straight out of that interview
if his arches
weren't killing him.
[ Laughter ]
The last operating prison ship
in the country
is set to close this week.
Well, you had a good run.
[ Laughter ]
The USDA today began
a raccoon vaccination campaign
in Nebraska,
except for one who's
doing his own research.
[ Laughter ]
Why is it on a football field?
And finally,
authorities in Florida
have warned residents
about a white truck
impersonating
a law-enforcement vehicle
that has a decal
that says "Booty Patrol."
But don't worry.
The FBI is investigating.
And that was the monologue,
everybody.